ever wonder what's under scp-049's  venetian plague dr mask perhaps we  should start calling zero four nine the  shy guy instead of zero nine six cause  we've never seen this guy's face  uncovered  maybe he's just a furry and his persona  is a goth bird maybe he's got a terrible  case of acne under there that he's  really self-conscious about  maybe he's hoping to be invited to an  eyes wide shut style mass swingers party  sometime soon and he's dressing for the  job he wants rather than the one he has  maybe underneath that mask he's dr oz  who's been using his daytime tv show to  help rid the world of the pestilence for  years maybe like the original plague  doctors he wears that so he doesn't  spread or receive contaminants in the  air  ah or maybe he just wears it because  under that mask he's butt ugly  oh what was that  i see  turns out scp-049's mask is made out of  bone and attached to his head it is his  face yikes  sorry buddy